[Music]
good morning
and welcome to a day in my life my day
begins in front of a screen where i will
check my inboxes
i'm a welfare lead for my university
which means i need to check that there's
been no emergencies during the night
i'm an executive assistant for someone
so i check their email and my tasks for
them
throughout the day and i'll check my
personal email which this morning was
very pleasantly empty
so now i can get dressed and leave
okay so we are ready to go the first
thing that we need to do is go to guys
campus where i'm going to complete a
drawing then we are going to hospital
that's going to be st
thomas's where i'm working on a project
with a couple of friends from medical
school
and then i have a bunch of classes and
meetings in the evening
so that's that's the day
[Music]
[Music]
so this drawing is actually not for
medical school um it's for
another degree that i'm doing in medical
art so
as part of my portfolio i need to
complete a drawing of
a femur which this is what i'm doing
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i just got home from the hospital we had
a short
session today because the doctor that we
needed actually wasn't there
so i get the afternoon off which means i
can get some studying done
so i'm just going to get changed and
then sit on my computer again
so this is me going through various
questions and lecture notes i've done
before
i'm also actually being quite naughty
here and
messaging with one of my friends from
work
since i spend a lot of my day just
sitting in front of a screen i like to
mix it up
and sit in various places within my room
you can blame this on lockdown
but yes here i'm sitting in front of my
window because the view of
the city is absolutely beautiful from
here
one of the things i love the most about
kings is just how many extra learning
opportunities there are
i am just finishing a course on
psychiatry where we get to be trained to
deal with very challenging patient cases
which is actually one of the funnest
things i've done in university so far
so this is what i'm doing throughout my
afternoon
[Music]
next i have a cat up call with my best
friend and it was supposed to be a
practice session for his upcoming sjt
exam
but it turned into a little therapy
session for me where i got to disclose
my absolute
terror at filming and publishing this
day in the life
he made me feel endlessly better about
feeling so violated by myself
and exponentially more terrified at
filming something so personal
so yep he's the reason to blame that
this is out
we eventually do get to the questions
and as always have
a great laugh at our own future epm's
expense
now all i need to do is check if there's
any welfare students that i need to talk
to tonight
and then perhaps i'll spend an hour or
so answering emails and sorting out some
tasks for work
and then i'm hopefully free to sleep
if you made it so far thank you so much
for watching and i hope you have a
wonderful rest of the day yourself
bye